so it gives me enormous pleasure to
introduce our speaker today our
distinguished speaker today is Professor
Brian Cantwell Smith
here's the Reid Hoffman professor of in
artificial intelligence and the human at
the University of Toronto where he is
also professor of information philosophy
cognitive science and the history and
philosophy of science and technology as
well as senior fellow at Massey College
as you can see he is an exemplar of an
interdisciplinary scholar in every
department pretty much a Toronto seems
to want him to be jointly appointed he
holds a BS and MS and PhD degrees was
almost a lifer but at MIT what escaped
from 81 to 96 he was a principal
research scientist at the Xerox Palo
Alto Research Center and adjunct
professor of philosophy at Stanford
University he was a founder of the
Center for the Study of language and
information at Stanford University a
founder and first president of computer
professionals for Social Responsibility
and president of the Society for
philosophy and psychology from 1996 to
2001 he was the professor of cognitive
science computer science and philosophy
at Indiana University and then he moved
on to a distinguished professorship in
philosophy and new technologies at Duke
again with appointments and philosophy
and computer science one reason why I'm
recounting his various appointments is
to really show you and to give you a
sense of preview of coming attractions
that you know he really is a scholar who
has talked very very deeply about has
been at the forefront of AI since the
first wave or even before the first wave
and has thought deeply about the
philosophical implications the ethical
implications of AI and so he moved to
the University of Toronto in 2003 and
from 2003 to 2008 he served as the Dean
of Faculty of information so his
research focuses on the philosophical
foundations of computation artificial
intelligence and mind and on fundamental
issues in metaphysics and epistemology
in the 1980s he developed the world's
first reflective programming language
three Lisp he is the author of on the
origin of objects and on the promise of
artificial intelligence reckoning and
judgment which is his recent book that
just came out his intellectual art and
research
interests are truly interdisciplinary
and as the brief bio that I gave you a
test today he will be talking to up to
us about what AI is what it is not what
it is capable of and what its limits are
so professor Brock Cantwell Smith
absolutely delighted
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks thanks so much Priya and and Thai
and the Frankie program for this
invitation a chance to come speak with
you you people have been so generous and
welcoming and it's really it's just
wonderful it's my honor and I appreciate
all of you giving up an hour or two of
your afternoon as well to think about
some of these things together I do want
to talk about reckoning and judgement it
comes from this little book I published
this book was supposed to be a paper
Terry Winograd who some of you will know
even when I was a graduate student he
said to me look Brian what do you think
is that email should be a paper what you
think is a paper should be a book and
what you think is a book should not be
written and the book I was working on
then is still not out and I think he
might have been right about the book
part so we'll leave that aside this is a
paper that happened to come out in the
form of a short book and why did I write
this book well because it seems to me
there's a difficulty in the current
debate about AI which so which has risen
to such prominence in recent years and
here's a way of caricaturing it if you
think about the depth of the
understanding of Technology and of
people that participants in this debate
have there's some people out here who I
think actually have a pretty good
understanding of the technology and the
implications and so on and so forth
boström and Kurtz while you know tegmark
and someone is always probably some of
you probably know this their names my
sense is that their understanding the
human condition is like a millimeter
deep unfortunately and the problem is of
course there are people who have a much
deeper understanding of human condition
content and MacIntyre I take people who
have actually passed on so that I'm not
quite taking their names in vain but but
you perhaps know such people even people
maybe in your families and so on and so
forth who think who have a real sense of
what humanity is and don't think
technology is there yet and then of
course there are people who don't really
have much of an understanding of either
which there are always those but what is
missing is the upper right quadrant
that's what I have felt there isn't
enough of a sort of serious debate about
what is going on if what matters about
it and what it's going to do and what
it's not going to do and how we can
think about it that's kind of there so
that's this
is attempted to say that in to make a
stab at articulating a few thoughts
about the upper-right quadrant
I mean particular I want to think about
how to think about AI and people and so
on without doing a whole lot of things
without considering it to be a contrast
between people and machines because that
way I think lies madness lots of reasons
for madness partly there are people some
of whom you will know the names of who
actually don't think we should be
imitating with art I mean it's not the
human condition should be vaulted into
prominences in fact the locus of
unexcelled saintliness i think but also
I don't think AI is stable either and
stuff in fact characterizing the debate
in terms of people versus machines in
fact is ideologically it's just wrong
what we need is a theory of intelligence
and the count of intelligence at least a
map of intelligence in terms of which we
can non circularly assess what kinds of
intelligence do AI sab now what kinds
did first wait I have what's happening
in this second wave what's may be
possible in the third wave are in the
future and also what kinds do people
have and what kinds can we expect to be
expected to have in the future because
there's no reason to think that human
intelligence is going to stay put just
as the rise of writing everybody who is
a story and documents this that what it
was to be human and so on and so forth
didn't didn't remain unscathed by the
development of writing in print in sub
there's no reason I think that the sense
of what it is to be human will remain
unscathed by the development of our show
and Shelton's either so I want to
basically a map in terms of in terms of
which to give some cartography to these
developments and in particular that's
not being a mystery story I'm gonna
actually make a distinction between two
things which are I think characteristic
ways of being intelligent I'm going to
divide them and I'm not going to use the
word intelligence anymore it's not like
I actually am not sure the word
intelligent is useful with respect to
the debates about what a are it should
probably be called si for
patek intelligence but anyway what is I
want actually some more specific terms
that I think we can understand things
better in terms of so by reckoning I
mean what I mean we're manipulation
representations and data and so on and
so forth about the world by systems that
are not themselves are responsible for
the relationship between those
representations and what they're about
in other words things that can't hold
the representations to account which i
think is really crucial and this is kind
of information processing the computers
excel at its characters of go fight
database programs simulations and so on
and so forth and what I'm gonna argue
today is its characteristic of deep
learning and machine learning and second
way by us as well that we haven't passed
past reckoning systems and I'm gonna
contrast that with what I call judgment
and ideal normative standard to which we
hold we humans should aspire and I just
a comment I think I've got a slide here
yeah normative is a tricky word it's
used in philosophy for something of
value it's also used in social science
for the thing that establishes the norms
are with respect to which abnormal
things are AB and I have colleagues who
are social scientists who say look norms
are bad which is a wonderful statement
because it's such a normative statement
in the philosophical term about the
sociological notion and so on and so
forth but anyway just for clarity I
don't mean to call anything abnormal I
just mean what is worthwhile and that we
should strive for this what do I mean by
a dispassionate deliberative thought by
dispassionately don't mean not
passionate I mean passionate
compassionate and dispassionate
basically impartial right something that
has is not you know torqued by your own
mishegoss basically not self-indulgent
ly emotion ladies careful deliberative
thought that universities I think ought
to be the locus of stewardship for in to
the extent Liz I honor Yale and all of
you grounded and ethical commitment
responsible action accountable to the
world inappropriate this situation is
which it's deployed so for example if
you want to hire a babysitter suppose
you thought this talk was worth
traveling hundreds of miles for and you
you you left your kid in the Berkshires
or something and with a babysitter for
three days and you decide
our drive down to Yale and stuff and you
have a good few days here you go back
and you say okay where's my two-year-old
and the babysitter says well I don't
know I haven't seen them for a couple
days but I did everything you told me
that's not good enough right you just
it's not just that it's not good enough
it's that you can't say everything that
is in fact what it is that the
babysitter should do you want a
babysitter with good judgment not
someone who is a literal responder to
instructions so for example suppose you
were to say look don't hand the baby
over to a strange man that seems like a
reasonable thing you might want to say
except maybe the apartment building they
live in starts to burn down and you
can't get down to the lobby anymore and
you know fire truck drives up with a
hook and ladder truck and the firemen
smash the windows and there's a guy
there and says hand me the kid first
I'll take it down and then I'll come
back and get you
we've only got a few seconds and you say
well no I'm not supposed to give the
child to a strange man that's not right
either in fact there's nothing you can
say by way of list of criteria for the
babysitter in virtue of the following of
which that babysitter would be a person
of good judgment that's a very serious
fact and this is why you want young
adults to take care of your kids so
that's what I mean by judgment something
what it is to have judgment in the sense
of having good judgment and I think one
of the things that is true about such
judgment is that it knows the difference
between appearance reality it knows the
difference between representations it
uses and the things in the world that
those representations represent it's
committed to its own existence and to
the world's existence and so on and so
forth basically and it defers to the
world that it knows the fundamental
axiom of science I guess that when word
and world part company in other words
when your ideas in the world part
company the world wins right you change
your ideas to match the world there's a
kind of deference to the world and I
think undergird science and I think it
undergirds basically having judgment and
they should undergird human relations I
think as well we were talking a little
bit about this and let's do the thing we
all know of what it is to have gone out
with someone in the past
whose was maybe in love with you but
listen I mean was in love with her image
of you but not with you and their love
was actually too attached to the
representation of you and it drives you
crazy you have to leave such a person
because he want to be with someone who's
committed to you not to their image of
you it was wrong they should update
their image or actually maybe stop being
in love with images altogether and
actually just be in love with you that
puts constitutes being an adults I think
all of these things are true of anything
that knows what they're talking about
and I actually will argue that we have
yet to build a computer system that
knows what he's talking about
okay so here's what I'm gonna argue deep
learning another second way you base I
systems convolutional neural networks
systems trained by reinforcement
learning and so on I mean all the recent
stuff that you've heard about they're
incredibly important so in this way I
want a side with the people out there on
the right-hand side of the graph their
power is enormous I think it's not only
increase I think the transformation of
the human condition that they will usher
in is is much bigger than a lot of
humanists believe but nevertheless none
of the things that are part of second
wave I will be into judgment and I also
don't think anything that is being
proposed for third wave a Ison leads in
judgment either so causal models of the
world the stuff that Josh Penn geo for
example at McGill one of the godfathers
of second wave AI he's working on causal
models no world proposals for dealing
with context which is what DARPA is
actually promoting it's actually what's
the next big thing we need in any high
nor anything else I have seen proposed
for third baby I don't think any of
those things are gonna lead to judgment
so that's really the tough lesson of
this
but then there's a question okay well if
none of these things will lead to human
judgement human judgment or to judgment
of any sort which humans at their best
can exemplify why is it that this stuff
is important and I think second wave AI
is important because it gives us
indirect but compelling evidence about
the nature of the world namely about
what it's like out there about the
ontological structure of the world and I
think there are lessons there that we
need to learn and we can ignore it our
peril in that first wave a I didn't
actually recognize with enough humility
so nevertheless so I want to look at
second wave AI a little bit from the
perspective reckoning a judgment and
actually ask what these systems can in
fact do and sort of by implication not
new but we'll get to that in the third
part so here is a way perhaps familiar
to all of you that deep learning is
characterized of nodes with lines
connected to other nodes in song earth
my sense is I think this is has a
property of what I call retrospective
clarity which is that it's clear to
people who already know what deep
learning is and conveys nothing to
people who don't that's a kind of
writing I used to excel at myself here
is a better form of characterization of
deep learning I think the deepening are
systems that do statistical
classification and prediction of
patterns based on often quite a lot of
sampled data using interconnected fabric
of processes and arranged in multiple
layers now I don't know if we exceed
can't for example and said what's this
new stop or Heidegger and said look you
know you're right rationale assigned a
progression Alfie's not not design
here's what design is
it's statistical classification of
patterns of you know based on I don't
think it would communicate much team
either so here's a third shot at
characterizing deep learning and I'm
doing this by contrast with go Fayyad
old-fashioned AI as John Hoagland dubbed
it if you don't know anything about
computing you can think of it as logic
formal logic is roughly the same he's
had an idea that human reason was
constituted by deep many step inference
by a serial process one
stream of consciousness or one
computational process or perhaps a few
of them but not a lot
using modest amounts of information
involving a relatively small number of
strongly correlated variables so if we
say Socrates is a man all men are mortal
therefore Socrates is mortal there very
few variables in that there's Socrates
which is a constant and being mortal and
being a man to two predicates that's it
not a lot and they're very strongly
correlated ah and an or and not and
implies SFR extreme strong correlations
between things so like formal logic
classical views of rationality standard
programs and stuff and deep learning is
the opposite in five dimensions so any
of you who's a good programmer should be
able to now generate the space of thirty
three different possibilities and put
these two things at opposite corners and
come up with lots of other architectures
but anyway it's basically shallow
inference just a few steps by a
massively parallel processor II using
massive amounts of information involving
a very large number of weakly correlated
variables now what does that mean why is
that crucial well if I recognize people
any of you next time pria for example
and I say hey there's a bunny in
Manhattan and I read you in the street
and then I say hey walking down the
other side sweet and the person says to
me well look you're a computer scientist
how do you recognize that that's Priya I
can't tell you which is going to be
immoral for explainable AI I think one
of the things that people are coming to
realize I think is that the way we
recognize faces is not by the thing on
the last thing oh there's certain eye
color and there's certain skin color and
there's certain height and they're
certain whatever and saying therefore
it's free or it's my partner or whatever
there are thousands maybe even millions
of micro variables which are extremely
weakly correlated with each other but
what the statistics of second wave AI
have shown is that lots and lots and
lots and lots of weak correlations can
sometimes lead to strong conclusions in
a way that's inaccessible to intuitions
which is an interesting fact and these
systems are very good at coming to the
conclusions that are weakly implied by
huge numbers of very weak meets rate
that are reasonably strongly implied by
huge numbers of extremely weak
correlations among a gazillion different
variables that's what's going on with
all the data mining and so on and so
forth
and that's proved enormously successful
in realms that first wave AI was bad at
you know face recognition and reading
x-rays and lots of things but okay so
that's good in this I mean I guess it's
good it's it's it's it proved successful
in certain cases but the questions why
is that proved successful and I think
the answer to that has to do with this
thing I said at the beginning which it
has to do with the nature of the world
out there so here are some examples this
is a room that this is I was in this
room it this is a picture from 1972 of
the room that shakey which was one of
the most famous of the first Brian here
we were in this room with shakey once
yeah anyway so
shakey was this this is shakey actually
on the wheels shakey didn't have to see
creaky shaking just saw these three
other objects and this whole set of
computer was just the peripheral driver
the computer itself was a big huge
mainframe it occupied a whole room that
was sudden theater that cable I mean
this is much less computing power than
nowadays this was the room that shakey
could deal with and could barely deal
with here's a picture that I that I
snarfed at random from the internet um
another room with like two or three
things in it two people at a table
without much on it and stuff and you can
parse this image this is a more
realistic picture than the previous one
a more realistic environment you can
parse this with no trouble at all but
here's the problem you have just looked
at this image in the sense that light
has reflected off the screen and gone
into your retinas and been processed by
your brain by a device consisting of a
hundred billion elements with a hundred
trillion interconnections that has been
honed for the explicit purpose of
actually understanding pictures like
this with 500 million years of training
namely your brain so there's an
interesting question what does this
sure actually delivered to your eyes
such that in fact that's what this
incredibly device has in fact processed
such as to give you an image of this
being a picture with a guy standing and
a Impa kind of table in it not so happy
woman standing nice window and stuff I
asked a Peter but what we did this with
everyone ever a very good friend of mine
who's a artist an amazing artist
actually in Madrid at a place called
factum arte but anyway he painted a
picture of what he thinks the world
looks like in the following sense this
is what okay the problem is you looked
at this image with that same hundred
billion element one hundred trillion
connections you can't there's no way to
get you to see what it is that your eyes
are seeing in the other picture it just
can't be done so he tried to paint
something that that I'll put it down
here for technical people among you if
perception computes function f of some
input then this is the artist conception
of F minus one of the inputs so then in
fact if you process this with your brain
the result delivered to your
consciousness will actually be what it
is that he thinks the world looks like
prior to brain processing okay got that
that'll be on the quizzes now I've been
in the place this is a picture up I've
seen it too often to not be able to read
it anymore I don't know how many of you
could read it um see if this thing works
okay so here's a guy walking across
there's a door here there's a pail here
with some sticks in it and in fact
inside the the the the door it's in a
basement there's a sort of crate there
with a bunch of sticks coming out of it
this is a couple of movies I mean you
know portable movie screens that happen
to be piled up against the wall and so
on and so forth over here is I think a a
bag of carpentry equipment and there's a
cell phone on the door there and so on
and so forth so I don't if you can see
that or not the lighting is not so great
here
but the basic point is that perception
involves parsing and rendering the world
intelligible in a way that is absolutely
non-trivial and the sort of conceptual
understanding of the will we have like
there's a person there's a table there's
that and all this kind of stuff is the
result of a huge amount of quote-unquote
intelligence so here's an analogy this
is a photograph of some islands in
Georgian Bay which is a place north of
Toronto where as it happens I have a
cottage although I promise you my
cottage is not in this picture there's a
lot of islands up there they they they
say they're 30,000 all those are
proposal to say the numbers should be
40,000 because nobody quite knows um
here though I've done something I've
cheated I've blocked me I've made the
water opaque here is the actual
photograph which shows the subterranean
the submarine structure and this is in
fact what this archipelago is like which
is there's just this incredibly
variegated underwater structure some of
which happens to prop to you know
poke up above the waterline and my sense
is that the objects that we have names
for the kind of conceptual ontology is
the word I'm using it for in the objects
and properties that we tend to write
about and think about in science events
on earth are in fact the things above
this conceptual level but the way we
recognize the world is not just
conceptually we recognize it by actually
understanding all the submarine like
namely all the things that I'm
analogizing to the submarine structure
so that is to say just to repeat that
the objects concepts categories and
stuff that are represented in current
database entries and symbols and
knowledge representations in logical
formula that we have words for in
natural language and that naive realism
and ngo5 first wavy I took to be the
fundamental ingredients in the world
aren't fundamental ingredients of the
world they are high-level abstractions
in idealizations that privilege some
information deprecated their information
clustering clump and coarse grain that's
a word that's used in computer science
classify according to interests and so
on and so forth
in ways appropriate to the projects at
hand this is a something that science
studies has talked about a lot but I
think it's just a pragmatic the
pragmatist too so suppose we decide to
climb all the 8,000 meter peaks in the
world then we're at the top of k2 and
you say okay this is our final wanna
brought this champagne you're gonna pop
up in the cork and and celebrate and I
say no look first of all the bottles
gonna explode it this out to do but but
secondly there's another peak 800 feet
over there that's also there was a
little bit of a peak that's gotta be
over 8,000 meters day we should go over
there time that that's not right that's
not considered an 8,000 meter peak
because the idea of a peak with respect
to climb in the 8,000 meter piece is in
fact specific to mountain climbing and
so on and so forth it doesn't just mean
all the local Maxima which are which is
may be relevant or something else like
possibly watersheds and stuff but the
planes I think conceptual ontology not
just the concepts but the properties in
the categories and the objects the
identity of objects themselves are in
fact perspectival a building commitments
and perspectives and so they're
inevitably quote-unquote biased or
skewed and so on and so forth that's
just how it is that's what it's like to
be in the world and to make sense of the
world without drowning in its detail but
another analogy I have analogized the
words and concepts all this conceptual
ontology stuff to the long distance
trucks and interstate highway systems of
intentional life intentional just means
mental there are ways of this is a word
I use registering the world finding the
world intelligible I think they're
crucial for anything like general
intelligence I don't think a robot or an
AI system or a person or any
like that could in fact navigate the
world without registering it in terms of
conceptual ontology because it shed so
much detail that you can in fact have a
chance of reaching out across the space
of time critical given our finite
resources to integrate the world into a
cohesive objective world critical for us
to communicate with others so that I
don't say oh look I had an old idea on
the way to work this morning can I
actually get a Thunderbolt 17 plug into
your spinal cord and I'll download 127
gigabytes of data which is my little
idea you know it just doesn't work like
that I also think they're critical in
order to plan imagine hypothesize
envision and so on and so forth things
that are crucial to - you know this
popper phrase we think so that our
hypotheses can die in our stead I think
it's a great comment right like if I
were to cross the highway right now but
look it's clear but actually there's a
truck I mean at 80 miles an hour it's
just over here and so on and so I
imagine if I tried the clock class it'll
quite be down so I'm not gonna cross so
your hypothesis of crossing has died but
fortunately you're still safe right
that's I think a crucial thing about
imagining and imagining requires not
thinking about the world in all this
detail where you would actually never
get across the street so conceptual
ontology is important but the cost of
the putting into the semi trucks and
interstate highway systems and stuff is
that you should so much detail that you
can't actually live locally and I think
the actual amount of detail you need in
order to pick and pick up a bottle of
water or a cup of coffee or shake hands
with someone or get her to door in
Sonora is stupefyingly more than you can
capture in words so here's sort of a
picture of logic databases first wave AI
and so on and so forth on the Left
you've got these conceptual categories
connected by a few lines and I think
human thought and communication is is
kind of like the thing on there right
they have all kinds of submarine
structure that is vastly complicated ly
interconnected and that's how we
recognize things and also this is so
what's my point
second wave a I believe machine learning
and so on and so forth is a
computational technique that hangs on to
the submarine detail so that it can do a
better job of perception and so that it
can do a better job of moving around
between the islands between and among
the islands in the fall of I'm gonna get
this wrong was it 2017 or 2018 I'm not
sure Google changed the algorithm
underlying Google Translate without
public notice from a previous version to
using Jeff Hinton's
deep learning based connections between
and among words where each of the words
was interconnected with thousands and
thousands maybe hundreds thousands maybe
millions of others with weak connections
and everybody noticed that Google
Translate got vastly better and I think
the point is that with respect to most
terms in language the interconnections
that actually render things sensible are
submarine interconnections that you
can't give voice to but in fact if you
have any common sense you will actually
realize so this is actually I'm gonna
pass by this this is a sort of idea
about what Third Way they I might do but
is this okay so the world is kind of
like that and given that the world is
like that it makes sense that second
wave AI would prove powerful with
respect to in fact responding to those
kinds of submarine inter connective
tissue so as to be better at things like
recognition for example on your cell
phone and stuff but I think these are
still reckoning systems so this is the
third part I think these systems the
second way VI systems don't remember
what my characterization of second wave
was they can't take responsibility for
the relationship between those
representations and the world that
they're about I think that takes
judgment so what's judgment here are
seven criteria that I think a system has
to have or meet
in order to be able to have anything
that I would count as legitimate ly
legitimate judgment in order to be able
to have that kind of what I'm taking to
be the substantive notion of
intelligence
first of all systems of judgment have to
be intentionally directed so intentional
is a philosophically technical term that
for now you can just think of as mental
maybe they have to be directed towards
the references representations not
merely towards the representation itself
or to the internal state or the causal
surround so you probably know this that
I don't think there are any pets that if
you point I mean they can respond to
things but they don't actually know that
if if I point it's not my finger that's
of interest it's where I'm pointing to
right that sense of directedness of
pointing the thing that's interesting is
if I say look there's a fire in the
lobby your mind will direct itself
towards that fire and you sort of think
oh goodness I better not go that door
I'll go with this one over here
something like that that's how we refer
to things if I refer to the ceiling on
the roof the paint flaking off the
ceiling on the examining room in the
clinic that mother Teresa used in what
was then called Calcutta all this kind
of stuff you can direct your mind
towards that you can direct your mind to
all kinds of things if you think you
need to get home today by six o'clock
then you're gonna direct your mind to
traffic and maybe get out of here
earlier and so on you can't imagine
thinking without your thinking being
directed towards something that's
basically what thinking is the thing
that's interesting about this kind of
directedness what really complicated
philosophical term for you is about this
you can't detect this physically it's
not something like a video camera will
capture it's not a form of causal
interaction that's a stop to why I
disagree with Karen broad for any of you
who are Brad fans that can't be kept on
a video camera is a Roberto of the tour
who actually thinks that video cameras
can capture everything of relevance to
science studies I believe I'm worried
that in fact reference can never won't
be ever accounted for in any kind of
science that he's committed to causal
explanation because it's
in a first instance a causal
relationship it may be constituted by
the total causal relations in the
universe I'm not arguing against
physicalism and QP detected so so I tell
my undergraduate this I say okay here's
an iPhone app you could build one for it
Android - if you build this and market
it you can become a billionaire in fact
I'm so confident you can be a
billionaire that if you build it and
market it and you don't become a
billionaire you can kill me you can take
my life I will put my life on the line
with respect to this being a billion
dollar apples the only problem is God
said you can't build it so here's the
app you put it on your iPhone and you
load it up and you put your button in
start then your iPhone will beep every
time anyone in the world thinks about
you now I think human vanity is such
that a lot of people would buy this app
and you can imagine Bluetooth
connections to earrings that would blow
and all those kind of stuff right so my
students sort of who are sort of
committed causal scientists say well
look of course you can build that after
you just instrument everyone's head and
you upload all of their thoughts to the
cloud and then you download you figure
out who they're thinking about and you
download that to the iPhone an infant
and something I actually don't think you
could do that for a variety of reasons
but but please and that's not what I'm
saying there's a fact at the moment now
as to whether someone's thinking about
you your partner for example but you
can't tell show you because nothing
causally impinges on you even though the
object of this thought so then my
students say well look actually there's
no such thing because if it's not causal
then in fact it doesn't exist
so they're not just causal scientists
they're metaphysically causal this so
then I try to get them worried and I say
look oK you've met someone three weeks
ago you're going a hot and heavy with
them and actually the last weekend
unfortunately their high school lover
came and they went off to Hawaii for
four days and you're just in your dorm
room you're complete anxious wreck and
you can't sleep and you can't eat you're
just a complete mess and then on Tuesday
your person comes back from Hawaii and
you say to them did you think about me
while you were gone and the person says
there's no such thing there's reference
I just changed around the organization
of my molecules and my brain is on his
earth
I just try to get him worried
some of them are remarkable leader about
in their denial that thought is about
anything but I think it's actually
unimaginable that thought is not about
something and nobody's that are
manageable but the aboutness matters
because for one thing it matters to the
truth of something in fact what's the
difference between fake news and real
news or true accounts and not true
accounts it has to do with the
relationship between the thing and what
it's about and that's not a direct
causal relationship you can't tell the
truth of something by putting a meter on
it there's no sensor that can sit on a
sentence and turn green when it's true
and turn red when it's false these facts
aren't causal relations in the world but
nevertheless I think this referential
orientation is the most important fact
about thought and language so many way
that's one criterion I'd better keep
speed up a little bit maybe I'll talk
faster in order to get a judgement I
think you've got to actually have that
orientation and I will say I don't think
any computers are oriented towards
anything at the moment you might say
look I put a USB key and I say look
erase this USB key isn't it oriented
towards the USB key and I think no it's
not it just sends some signals out to
some thing that's wired into that Drive
but if you take that out and put a
different one in so that drivers gonna
erase that one and it's not that it you
could tell the difference yourself if
you were in that situation but you know
the difference the system is no it's
congenitally unable to know the
difference between what's in the drive
and another thing that looks causally
the same to it so anyway yeah there's an
issue of whether science as we know it
can explain the mind that's a that's
something sure we can talk about
secondly this is this registration thing
I mentioned earlier I think you have to
find a world intelligible which means
abstracting skewing clustering
identifying and so on and so forth
identifying objects and so on and so
forth other ways that are appropriate to
the projects at hand and crucially you
need to understand it and relation ways
that are appropriate to the commitments
and the identity of objects and
properties and stuff that underwrite the
registration scheme so that's going to
matter on American Airlines for example
you're an adult if you're over two
your nano because you need your own seat
if you're doing a study of smoking and
children you say very few children smoke
because I checked this database of
American Airlines and nobody in fact was
caught smoking and stuff like that's a
different notion of adults right you've
got to understand that if you're gonna
actually do this this stuff about
databases and so on and so forth there
are commitments underlying all the
categories I'm answering this one before
I think to have judgment you've got to
know the difference between appearance
and reality and that means knowing the
difference between your own
representation and what it is the
representations about which means you
need to know what the representations
are about and you can't just know by
having other representations because
then you would just have commitment to
other representations but remember this
person you don't want to live with you
want them to be committed to you not to
just another image of you and I think
this gets into John Hoagland and other
philosophers
I mean parts of Heidegger that I think
are okay and lots and stuff like that
about discriminating the actual and the
possible be impossible and so on and so
forth this is a very complex condition
so for example pre was kind enough to
bring me this bottle of water if I saw
or in some sense if my visual system
delivered to my head the following idea
that this bottle of water just jumped
off and went back down on that table
now I good physicist so I think well it
must have cooled down because we've got
to be conservation of energy what I
think that that happened no because it
can't happen I mean yeah it could happen
if a vitally to the second law but it's
not it's not gonna happen it's just not
gonna happen and in fact in my visual
system delivered to me that impression
that that bottle just jumped up and down
I would think I just blinked in fact it
may have done it I wouldn't know I would
think I blinked or I would think I
jostle the the lectern or I think you
have a subway underneath this wonderful
hall which you probably don't all right
we think that whatever I was fed at
lunch it's wonderful lunch actually
there was something in it it wasn't just
water in coffee whatever I would make up
some story that he's possible in the
world to explain the fact that I thought
something happened that we
impossible because I have very high
standards on taking something to be the
case and you might say well look you
should just have a a model a
cosmopolitan
what is possible but the problem is that
the conditions on being actual
impossible and impossible all kind of
suffer conditions on registration
schemes there in part they're not just
conditions on how you're interesting in
particular the conditions on schemes so
for example that this will have jumped
up and cool off is compatible with some
registration scene but it's not
commendable with other ones but that I
don't know it just got infused by I
don't what's something impossible it
just turned into single malt that just
can't happen so I'm not gonna entertain
that but it's not part of my
registration scheme of bottles of waters
that they can't talk turning into single
malt do there's there's background
conditions on in fact ways of finding
the world intelligible that keeps out
what's impossible which I don't think
any computer system has yet more
existential philosophy I think they've
got to be steaks there's got to be
commitment the system has to care about
the difference between itself in the
world be existential II involved in its
domain and so on and so forth these
things are necessary in order for it to
know what in fact it can take is real if
if you can't tell the difference between
if you don't know what it is for
something to be wrong you don't know
what it is for something to be right and
if you don't know the difference between
something and being wrong or something
right you can't tell the difference
between your representation in the world
and you just turned back into a sort of
internal solipsistic so the existential
commitments I think on knowledge are is
not my idea this is really really
serious I also think you have to hold
everything accountable to being in the
world this was one of the problems I had
with this little love with you possible
is that that requires a world that there
can't be and what do we maybe the world
I don't mean any single registration
scheme of it and in conceptual model of
it rosy I mean the thing that in fact
conceptual models are models of which is
to say
the world as a whole right that which is
one I mean I could invoke language that
would be reminiscent of sent 19th
century conceptions of God that which
transcends all understanding that to
which everything is accountable and so
on and so forth except I don't mean God
in some sense is different from the
world I mean what's out the world out
there is staggeringly complex and it is
more complicated and more subtle and
more nuanced and so on and so forth then
I can grasp but my commitment has got to
be to it and it that I register as a cup
not to the cup quake up you always have
to have this commitment to to that which
is beyond how it is that you take things
to be and that's what I mean by res
resolutely defer you have to be
deferential about the adequacy of your
registration schemes for those who like
science semantics I want to say
semantics has to be deferential needless
to say model theory is not a model of
semantics that I think is worthy because
it's not differential and needless to
say I don't think any computer systems
we have built at the moment are
deferential like this and I don't even
know that I know how to build something
differential I think everything has to
be accountable I won't go into this I
mean it's it's it's it's similar it's
actually involves being accountable
yourself for your own participation in
the world not just for the things being
in the world and you have to have a
sense of self you have to know that you
are here but at the same time you have
to detach yourself from what you know so
is in fact that you can think that this
things that you're saying about this
thing are true and they're not just
projections of you so all the models of
objectivity in the West about scientific
knowledge and all the models of serious
detachment from the eat from East you
know we should use those words um but
anyway from Asia I think are both models
of how to step aside from your own
mishegoss to use that technical term
again so is to let things be what they
are without denying that you're located
in your have a perspective on them
that's I think giving things their due
that's kind of my philosophy of life is
you should give things that are due and
I think that is amazingly hard and I
think you have to give you things there
do in order to be a creature that has
the
judgment so something like that all of
those things I think are required in
order for a system to know what is
talking about at least for it to know
what it's talking about in any way
that's really worthy and needless to say
I don't think anything in first way by a
second wave of AI or models causal
models and models with context and so on
and so forth actually approach this
because I think like the point about
referential orientation it's not obvious
what it takes to have these kinds of
non-causal orientation towards the
things that you're talking about so it
wouldn't say look so are you a mystic
and stuff you don't think it's possible
to ever build a system it as judgment
and my feeling is no I'm a physical
ystem alright the point is I think
judgement is unlikely in machines to be
an architectural property of a computer
system that's identifiable as a local
architectural property or identify on
fMRI no more locally identify well then
we could locally identify what your
beliefs are true or whether in fact your
inference is trustworthy or your
personal reliability so my dad just if I
can have a personal note here he was
president of American Academy of
religions and he was a Christian but he
he was involved in in working with
Muslims as colleagues he started this
Islamic Institute in Montreal and she
was asked on stage are you a Christian
and he said well I don't know about that
asked my neighbor he didn't say where's
the nearest fMRI and I think you know
for an off-the-cuff the response I don't
know he made it up right there but
anyway it's a pretty good response I
think to what mattered to him about his
I mean I'm not really just but his
religious orientation is treat your
neighbor well and treat your neighbor
well is not an architectural property of
the brain you're not gonna find it on an
fMRI and I think for computer engineers
that's an issue because at the moment we
build
so that we can actually sort of
understand with respect to the mechanism
that goes on inside their skull but
really my point here today is that the
properties that actually are the
properties that are constitutive of a
judgment aren't characterized about in
terms of properties that are F ibly
identifiable in terms of properties of
the stuff inside the computer skull
basically I mean I'm not a physicalist
no I think it's probably embedded in
adoptee erratically understandable as
extraordinarily complex fine structures
of neural patterning specific to
particular people in circumstances
establish a deep cultural betting and so
on so in general my sense is that
developing the norms and inculcating
them in people and civilization or
cultures and so on and so forth is a
huge accomplishment over the last ten
thousand years let's say or 40,000 years
or something of human culture is
actually figuring out how to encourage
these normative standards for people too
huge
so then the question is can can you
build these things in principle
presumably yes right if in fact we gave
these systems enough guidance and of
cultural embedding enough education and
enough Abin a cycle taproot enrolling a
highly complex social configurations you
know which we've come to recognize this
crucial development it's kind of moral
compass and so long as ever so my
partner she's a neuroscientist says she
had a ten year old plan I got together
with her when he was like 14 I said to
her look I don't think I was saying this
to you right before the thing so that's
why I'm coming up with the example I
said you know so my father's the alert
and I sort of said look I don't think is
moral tackle too deep enough and she
looked at me and she said he's not
myelinated yet so that's what happens
when the alert runs into a neuroscience
but she didn't disagree that he didn't
yet have an appropriate moral compass to
in fact deal with situations and you
know what you do as a kid you know that
kids playing hockey in the backyard and
they breaks a plate-glass window in the
neighbor's house and she's ashamed and
never wants to talk to the neighborhood
anymore and you say look you know we're
gonna take my hand we're gonna go over
and we're not gonna
we're gonna explain to them and I know
you're terrified but he's a decent guard
she's a decent got a decent person and
they'll understand and so on it was an
honest mistake and I'm gonna pay for the
window and so on and so forth and you're
gonna say to your sorry it happened and
we're gonna do that and the kid screams
and you say no you hang on to their head
firmly it's a it's what they call it a
object lessons I mean it's a it's a
point of moral education what I don't
know is what would it be to actually
take systems of our synthesis our
construction through the kind of
development that is necessary in order
for them to develop this kind of moral
commitments to transcend self-interest
to be committed to the whole to get over
greed and petty jealousy all this kind
of stuff um something has been talked
about in great literature as I said in
their world religious traditions I don't
think you're gonna get a big data
training set that's gonna generate this
and of course people can say but what
people aren't too good at that either
and I say well that's good I mean that's
not good that's a good point because in
fact that's why I don't want to
characterize a high in terms of for
people's failings the point is we want
to actually build systems we can rely on
and this is what we as a human culture
have come to realize is necessary in
order for us to rely on people and
here's the sort of blunt way of
nastiness I've asked this to a variety
of my students who work in Silicon
Valley what would it be for you to build
a system that needs to be educated or
raised rather than just trained and I
don't know the answer that and neither
do they okay so what can we learn from
this exploration systems lacking in
judgment systems that don't have this
judgment that I've been talking about so
everything in go fie everything in
databases everything but also everything
in deep learning and everything in
second wave a I believe can't shoulder
responsibility because in fact it's not
committed to that which its
representations represent and that's the
sort of first step towards
responsibility so they can't rule
responsibility at all so therefore they
themselves cannot be ethical or
unethical they can't take responsibility
for the registration of the world
because in fact they don't have any
access to the world of the registrations
or registrations of they can't take
respondent for that which they register
so they can't take Rafael D for the kid
if you had an AI system that you wanted
to employ as a babysitter if they can't
take responsibility for the data in
terms of visits they were trained
because they have no I mean have nothing
remotely approximating the capacity to
take responsibility for the data they're
trained in so it follows that if we
build such systems we use them we have
to shoulder all the deference to the
world that is relevant to the data they
are trained on and use we have to take
responsibility for all the objects
registrations and registration schemes
that the system uses or relies on that
means we have to take responsibility for
the registration schemes underlying all
of the databases that they're mining the
categories like sex one's got sex one's
got gender and stuff right there's five
viable sexes I think with respect to X X
X Y X Y X X Y X or not I'm pretty sure
all five of those are viable there's
gender there's there's pina typical sex
at birth so in fact if you're XY but you
don't have androgen reception's you'll
grow up FINA typically female you might
you probably wouldn't know that you're
XY and all this kind of stuff
so you've got a driver's license and it
just is a one big field of male or
female and stuff we have to take
responsibility for the violence that's
doing to all kinds of different persons
there's a question of whether driver's
license should have sex or gender on
them and actually a friend in previous
somebody worked in in the in the lab
when I was Dean that's his job at the
moment he's to investigate changing the
contrary a driver's license to actually
allow people to change the field on
their driver's license and the question
is should that feel be called sex or
should it be gender should there be
another field and so on and not a
trivial problem but the point is we have
to take responsibility for all of the
categorization underlines all of the
databases that in fact systems are
trained on
and I therefore am not at all convinced
that Dana mining is ethical because I
actually believe that data mining is
runs rampant over all kinds of data
bases but I'm not sure anybody has said
look I'll stand up and take
responsibility for the fact that their
registration schemes underlying all of
these databases are actually ethically
compatible with respect to all the
purposes that this system is actually
going to be deployed in and so on and so
forth in other words the successes of
second wave a I don't absolve us from
any of this stuff that I think is true
at the moment and I think the standards
I've tried to articulate for judgment or
what it is that a system would have to
achieve in order for us to be exculpated
from taking all of that on our own
shoulders and then one of the lessons
for people well I think we should
allocate to a is all the tasks for which
their reckoning prowess suffice it
reading x-rays maybe if the circumstance
of right
what about driverless cars well does
that require judgment I don't think
that's a question with a simple answer I
think in fact if this structure of
driving were sufficiently regulated then
in fact it could be that reckoning
systems would be appropriate for that
and it might be that beam a much safer
than people the way the structure of
flying airplanes is regulated such that
in fact computers are in fact largely
responsible for a lot of the lending of
planes and I'm glad when I fly into San
Francisco Airport and it's foggy that
their computers in there and not a pilot
peering out the window saying you don't
really think the airport is you think
it's they over there who's done you know
yes we should have computers but we
regulate flying such that computers
prowess is adequate at the moment we
don't have driving configured in such a
way that reckoning prowess suffices how
that will go I honestly don't know but I
think the point is what we need to do is
what would driving have to be such that
in fact reckoning would be enough to
make driving safe and if it's not we
shouldn't actually turn it over so I
want vocabulary in terms that we see
that problem not yet to make a judgement
about what it is that would be right I
also think this is the university that
we should up the ante on educating
people so that they shoulder judgment
not because of the audit culture that
unfortunately affects the university of
chronometer it doesn't actually affect
any of you here not actually reduce
education to actually train students to
be good reckoners which systems are
going to be much better than they are at
but say look shucks all of the skills
you're taught that actually can be done
by reckoners what that you're doing
requires your judgment and amplify build
that up nourishing and inspire that in
our students so that's what I want to
say thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you thank you so much for an
excellent talk that is forcing all of us
to think much more deeply about sort of
news items that we are reading about
what a I can and can't do so now we open
the floor for questions and there's a
roving mic ah
thanks yeah yeah hi thank you if I walk
around looking blinded it's actually
because I am because they're bright
lights up there sorry about that
to what extent do you think a system
with judgment might need to be local or
like situated or embodied or some of the
words I heard right
well okay to what extent do a big exam
what's the next no look I don't think
rationality is keys think about the
submarine structures which I think are
necessary in order to think well even
think in a reckoning way in order to
have that submarine structure you've got
to be somewhere in the world such as you
absorb it and stuff take the word
laughter it's actually interesting on
Thursday I'm giving a talk in Pittsburgh
a couple talks there but one of its
called effing the unethical um and I
think it's basically about what can how
can words give voice to that which words
cannot give voice to think about
laughter I could say they laughed at him
when he came into the room or you know
she's capable of making anybody laugh
you know and it's so disarming of
tension you know what this predicate
laugh means do you think Oh laugh of her
then I don't think so I think laughter
indexes for you a vastly hump like
submarine structure because you have
left and I don't think any system is
going to be able to actually do
with they laughed that is not itself a
system that laughs and you're not gonna
laugh if you're not somewhere I mean
maybe the Oracle of Delphi and God
laughs I don't know but but laughing is
something that happens and you I mean
think of all the things that have to be
true for you in order to laugh the thing
that's interesting though about the
embodied body myth stuff first of all
I'm not a fan of the word embodiment cuz
okay so I'm gonna have some water now
I'm gonna drink from an embodied bottle
of water there's something weird about
calling us an embodied bottle of water
it's physical it's concrete it's here
but you wouldn't say it was embodied why
would you not say is embodied I think
because it would never occur to you that
it wasn't you know I worried that people
would talk about embodiment or actually
lapsed Catholics or something that
actually think there could be the human
soul without the body so people say look
you've got to take care of your body I
would say look you gotta take care of
yourself I mean cuz that's you so it's a
funny word in intellectual history I
think to have taken this thing on to
name what I think is a property that is
so true that it shouldn't need to be
named but that we have to be concretely
here and that we have to look at it in a
context I think is absolutely critical I
don't think it's enough the problem is a
lot of the radical embodiment people
want to reduce thinking to concrete
causal bumping and shoving around them
and I think they can't think about the
pot on the stove that is currently
burning up their apartment because
they're not concretely connected to it I
mean I think the whole point about
reference not being a causal
relationship is that it it is something
that the radical embodiment and situated
people are unable to account for so yes
but is my answer
someone else I don't know where the
microphone is
I'll have to make good on my promise
here yeah wouldn't ask you about yeah
the relationship between self and
consciousness right particularly in the
concept or in the context of animal
sense of self in animals and continental
consciousness and to think about that in
the context of the possibility of
computer conscious our sense of self or
feelings okay great question um here's
what I think I mean I have a whole story
I want to tell about consciousness at
some boy this is not that story
oddly enough I want to talk to Priya
about this theory because it actually
relates to differential equations in
physics and so on which is unlikely
thing but anyway but here's the problem
I think there is a model of rationality
which has been based on first-order
logic and they're improving on stuff
which has been held up as a norm of
that's what it is to be rational and
that's you know and and that involves a
variety of things one is a particular
form of moving between propositions and
the propositions are conceptually
articulated and so a lot of people have
realized that's not all there is to
human mental life and my worry is a lot
of people have put into consciousness
all of the things that that model of
Reason can't hold there was a
consciousness conference at which David
Chalmers they were talking about qualia
the feel of and he said let's start the
conference with some qualia so he put on
like a Brahma string quartet for five
minutes and
I think that's actually perverse I think
there is something about the sound of a
Beethoven string quartet that is not
capturable in this loads assist model of
thinking or enlarge assist model logic
based model of perception but so much
the worse for the largest cysts logical
logic based models of thinking and
perception I think I actually think that
they are based on an untenable
ontological view of the world and that
consciousness has served us the else
Clause under which a rug under which
everything else has been swept and I
think if you develop the notion
rationality that I think is implicit in
notion of judgment a huge amount of that
which gets put into consciousness ends
up in this account that that's actually
something that in fact is necessary to
thought at all
now one thing you can ask is well look
if that's true I'm not saying you think
it's true but suppose you were to say to
me look if that were true does that mean
there's no difference between thought
and consciousness and I don't think the
answer is no I mean I don't think
answers yes I don't think it's no either
I think it's complicated because I think
consciousness involves taking the self
to be yourself and there's there's a lot
of things like that so then we can talk
about oh I don't know dance a hobby
whose a phenomenologist in Copenhagen
who has written very I think
penetratingly about consciousness and
self and over but I think the the first
order is I want to be careful about the
question because I worry that the notion
of consciousness is carrying a lot of
stuff which i think is absolutely
fundamental I just am not sure it's
helpful to put it under consciousness I
start because I worry that then people
will say what these machines cannot be
conscious but there still be intelligent
and my worry is that know what notion of
intelligence is that I don't think it's
anything more than reckoning I think
anything that deserves to be called
thought has to have a lot of what
matters to you that you put in
consciousness so that's kind of how I
would structure that discussion and then
I would buy you a pint
well I very much like what you said
about the implementation of judgment and
a quite agree on that statement at the
very end but I will play the devil's
advocate and genetics recently there is
this trend where there's a questioner
that would be asked to a number of
people and a certain I mean radically
socially and culturally constructed
trait would be quote unquote measured
like how and pathetic a person is or how
reckless they are and there will be a
Sanders court and then data mining comes
next to find some correlations between
some genetic biomarkers and these traits
so how would you respond for example if
someone tells you I can actually predict
with 95 percent accuracy from the fMRI
if a person would be empathetic to their
neighbors or not okay so couple things
first of all if if you could predict of
a person whether they were gonna be
empathetic then I wouldn't be
particularly impressed because I like I
said I'm not trying to I'm not a duelist
I don't think the way we are is
independent of our physical realization
but what has constituted the development
of an empathy and what it is to in fact
be empathetic towards others and stuff I
think the notion is in fact a relational
notion between us and people in other
than us I don't think you're gonna get a
neuroscience marker of truth and I think
empathy is ultimately as externally
oriented as truth
and also there's a real question about
whether empathy is self-indulgent or not
so you know I met somebody who
apologized all the time and I said about
them you know this is somebody who's
apologizing because it makes them feel
better it's not actually you know a
gesture to the other I don't you know I
don't deny that there may be markers of
this stuff but that doesn't mean that
its explanatory of what empathy is or
then in fact a situation might not call
forth empathy which was not manifested
in affective feeling you know in
physiological so imagine that you're
you're a hit injury or something and
your partner is there trying to take
care of you in the hospital and you
might not make it but you just want to
demonstrate enormous empathy for this
partner who's going through this hell
and may lose you and stuff you may be
incapable of you know the the the the
neurophysiological expression of empathy
that those tests would mark but it may
be that you can recruit other ways of
expressing the empathy which you
actually feel in ways that the marker
wouldn't find so if you think about the
debates about behaviorism
in psychology which this is actually I
think a replay of there were people who
said look you could tell things by
how people behaved but behaviorism was
just outside right and basically it was
no any generalization gonna come up with
effective behaviorism you could tell a
person something ahead of time such that
they don't behaving the appropriate way
that circo's that and I actually think
all this narrow scientific testing of
everything is basically internal
behaviors it's saying you can reduce the
human condition to the bumping and
shoving and electrical measurements and
so on and so forth of all the ins I'll
stop and I think the fundamental fact
about generosity and talking and
speaking for the truth and standing for
the truth and doing unto others and all
kind of stuff has to do with your
relation allottee to that which is other
and I don't think that which is other is
so constant that you can as it were
parameterize it out into an internal
test I just think it's gonna be a
shallow marker something like that you
so much I'm very curious about a is
relationship about systems of judgment
in relations to ethic and moral moral
intersection with nation-states and how
they monitor police their populations
and specifically what comes to mind is
Google's relationship now with China
developing social currency which is
their current experiment and how they
monitor facial expressions reading lips
are those kinds of things and and what
is it well for us in the future as other
nation states kind of accept these kinds
of ways of policing their populations
well I might have to buy you a drink
before we even get started the other
gentleman I listen I'm I'm actually not
an optimist I'm a romantic I worry about
these things
I worry pretty profoundly I think that
the transformation of the physical
conditions of human life including
international are so profound that the
norms and structures and stuff that we
built up in the last ten twenty thirty
thousand years in fact a lot of them
aren't applicable and we don't have any
Normandy governance on behavior at that
realm I think that you know this might
make right we don't typically think it
does anymore because we've thought that
through with respect to nations those
surveillance make right you know there's
no doubt as a as the gentleman was
asking there are correlations between
and among things there are a lot of
correlations in that world is that the
real thing I don't think so I don't
think people on connect so I actually
don't think people in trying to think so
either
but you know there's it's pretty
interesting I have a number of Chinese
graduate students and I've talked to
this about you know and most of them
realized that the Chinese state is kind
of totalitarian on the other hand they
think that what's going on in the US is
terrible enough that they actually would
prefer to Talat arianism than the chance
their kids are gonna get shot in school
and you know these are these are pretty
weighty things to weigh the relative
demerit zone but I don't think these are
good policies I think they're
misconceived that you can in fact get at
moral character or something like that
from facial recognition I think that is
just more behaviorism you know it's a
particular form of behavior the room and
behaviorism died a I don't think the
mineus death it's too strong but anyway
it's not really respected as a theory of
psychology anymore
but I think the discourse of AI is in
fact feeding into it and something else
I might say is that
okay just quickly computer science came
out of sort of the rationalist tradition
right so Descartes comes along and he
sort of says look there's all these
stuff we can figure it out we'll call
that mechanism the under stuff is
rationality I'm not gonna put into it
and retain rationality the mechanism
stuff flying planes and songs over big
success bigger success in Microsoft you
know so it goes and it starts explain
more and more and more and then people
say well look maybe we can explain
rationality and stuff I don't know if
you know but geoff hinton who's the
godfather of deep learning his
great-great-great grandfather was george
boole who invented boolean logic so the
norms in his family on what constitutes
success are actually pretty high and he
has felt weighted down by these for
thirty years of doing so anyway anyway
but bool was involved in sort of trying
to render the rational into the
mechanical in part but nobody thought
semantics could be rendered it was just
proof he was just the causal mechanisms
of thought not the aboutness computer
science comes along and think about the
technical terminology of computer
science data information program
identifiers name reference semantics you
know reference to us data to an index
array or something
computer science took all of the cab you
Larry from the rationalists and
translated into mechanism so all of what
semantics is in computer science is a
McKee I'm an account of the mechanical
relationship between a program and the
behavior that the mechanically
individuated behavior to which it gives
arise so if I talk to computer
scientists about semantics they think
I'm saying garbage and then the problem
with that is that I'd actually don't
have any words to speak about that which
I want to speak to them about because
they've taken my words so we've got a
problem with respect to bringing these
issues up in a way that is intelligible
to computer science and I tell you I
have been struggling with this for 30
years
it's not easy now you could say look
forget those words I've been told by
people and audiences for
look just get with the program it's just
over you know that's what all these
words mean now well well yeah well it's
Mike sort of technical response to a lot
of things um it's a real intellectual I
mean we are in a battle about the age of
mechanism because I think computing is
interesting because it is not just a
mechanical phenomenon and so this is the
last gasp of the limits of mechanism and
the computer science industry and maybe
Google too are trying to subsume it into
a mechanical account and I think what's
happening to the notion of intelligence
is the mechanist are trying to render it
into a mechanical thing and that's why I
talk to the students about you know
reference not being detectable I think
it's crucial that we realized that the
locus of what matters about us as people
is not reducible to mechanical
vocabulary and that it is not implied by
being a physicalist either cuz that's
another oh you're just a mystical
whatever you know you've been out of
date since fourteen a tourism so there's
real stuff and stay here I think I don't
want to be accessible your matter okay
in the footnote sorry so we're all
looking forward to this drink which for
the Frankie program is going to devise
so I will try to keep you short
everything you said as seemed to be very
much at the human scale even essentially
at the human scale so I take it to be
perfectly okay the you mentioned quantum
mechanics great my worry is that by
doing so what what you need to be taking
account of is Bohr's view of measurement
and compatibility where for instance at
the human level you and I could look at
a person's behavior and I might say oh
that behavior is acceptable then you
might say that behavior is unacceptable
right and of course we're making
completely incompatible assessments my
whole history leads me to think that
their behavior is except to throw your
whole history
we've both made a binary measurement
which we give the same day interim and
yet they're from completely different
directions into the same what we would
think is the same behavior and yet
is there a factor of the matter because
that's what quantum mechanics says is
that if you are making incompatible
measurements then there is a much more
serious question as to whether there is
a fact of the matter of what you'll see
a much almost or everything you could
have said yeah it's very much focused on
there being a fact to the matter
and I'm not saying of course evolution
means but is now I'm starting to make
this into a comment instead of a
question on dice that's right you can
just say do you think that was true I
suppose you must have been confronted by
people who said what about quantum
mechanics yeah yeah yeah so I guess
having made my comment I'd love to know
what your response has matured into to
people who say what about one mechanics
well I think you were succeeded in
making a question short whether you
succeed and ask a question to which the
answer is short it's a difficult
different question um
okay first with respected I mean a fact
of the matter I think facts of the
matter actually I mean I have
constructivist sensibilities as you can
tell from my other book head from this
book and so on and so forth so I think
what constitutes truth is to some extent
I mean it's undergirded by the world but
I think it actually is reflected in an
appropriate attitude for us to take
towards the world so for example if we
you and I climb this mountain and is it
true that there's another 8,000 meter
pika has to do with in part with our
commitments as well as with geography
it's not that I'm changing the geography
I'm not constructing a geography but as
to the fact it's it's more complicated
that so I actually have pretty serious
constructivist leanings with respect to
some aspects of the facts of the matter
I don't think they are black and white I
also don't think that things not being
black and white undermines the
robustness of the categories in terms of
which they're framed so for example I
think bread it's a very useful category
in the world if I say well look what
about lockets what about Hot Cross Buns
what about you know I don't know Oreo
cookies I don't know something you know
something something else these pancakes
are they bread I mean
you know if that's kind of facetious to
worry about whether either it's like
forget it you've got a PhD I mean MIT to
audience get a life up but that doesn't
mean or if I said look you think Brent's
a good category let's have the opposite
of bread for supper like it doesn't have
an opposite um but it doesn't undermine
look everything is bread right it
doesn't liquefy anything to just smoosh
to say that the memories aren't sharp or
that they don't have opposites and stuff
I think there's a huge amount for us to
learn from the robustness of categories
that don't meet the sort of logical
conceptions of what constitutes a
category and I think that's relevant to
facts into truth - that doesn't address
the car mechanic stuff I think why we
are the mesoscale creatures that we are
is actually an issue of some note I
don't want to pretend we aren't I do
think that two things bear on the way
our judgment has emerged given we are
them as though scale creatures that we
are one of them is the statistical the
you know system the overwhelming
statistics of in fact things at the
scale at which we take them to be
objects in the course of our ordinary
life and stuff and another thing is that
the complexity results in computer
science are pretty serious I think with
respect to in fact figuring things out
so there's this wonderful I don't know
if your those are your computer science
may get this otherwise they probably
know sense but there's this wonderful
hypothesis of what if the world was
running the optimal algorithm so that
there was no way to predict what was
going on except by being a whole world
and waiting until it happened that's
actually the optimal way to figure it
out you know there's this fantasy that
if things are determined and they must
be predictable but I think lots of
scientific results in 20th century
science had driven a wedge an
irrevocable wedge between determinism
predictability so there were facts above
quantum mechanics or facts about
computability Theory there's factor of
statistics and so on and so forth said I
think relevant to that
there's something else that comes up
with retro quantum mechanics which
people say to me all the time and
actually they tend to invoke care and
we're out here that look you say
references not causal but maybe it's a
causal entanglement you know whatever
there's quantum entanglement that in
fact transcends space-time locality is I
think it's like I mean I think that's a
fantasy which is a little bit redolent
of excessive physical ISM and then
people tell me funny things they said
quantum mechanics is crunches I mean
three sorry I'm tired
quad consciousness is corner mechanical
and I say you know what you're right
have a glass of whiskey we'd like I said
it here since ice you know what this ice
is quantum mechanical - and not only is
a quantum mechanical because quantum
kennix is true but why is the ice
floating in the whiskey
it can only be explained at the quantum
mechanical level so it's not just that
it's quantum mechanical it's the
explanation of its macroscopic
properties relies on quantum mechanics
does that mean I've had a mystical
revelation about the ice and my whiskey
not until I drink it anyway um you know
so what it's interesting it's
interesting science but it's not I've
never heard an argument that quantum
consciousness is quantum mechanical that
I thought made any interesting axis to
the undoubted fact that the physical
basis of quantum akancha statistic
supervenes on top of quantum mechanical
properties of the universe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]